buenas tardes el juez rafael martínez
acaba de rechazar un pedido de
postergación de audiencia por parte de
la defensa de uno de los acusados la
mayor parte de la mañana se ha usado
para debatir este pedido la fiscalía ha
iniciado la lectura de cargos contra el
ex presidente alberto fujimori sus ex
ministro de salud es barrio motta marino
costa bauer y alejandro aguinaga miles
de mujeres y hombres los acusan de
haberlos esterilizado contra su voluntad
entre los años 1996 y 2000 el ex
presidente fujimori va a ser juzgado es
virtualmente el viene cumpliendo una
condena de 25 años de prisión por
violación a los derechos humanos según
diversos juristas el caso de las
esterilizaciones forzadas constituye un
delito de lesa humanidad y si la corte
lo halla culpable va a ser muy
complicado para el gobernante aplicar a
un indulto a una reducción de condena